the um I wanted to do a bit of a
slightly different talk um I know a lot
of the the workshop are about letting
people go
through
um what is the a bit of code explaining
the decisions the ideas and the benefit
and I think that's very a useful kind of
Workshop I did a couple of those in the
past P London mostly um but I think
there's been a question on everybody's
mind lately um and even if it feels like
it's a very new question it's a question
I've heard before uh and I would wanted
to use this opportunity to have what I
think is actually a workshop where I
expect a bit more
interactions uh then um when you just
throw a lot of code at
people around um what does it mean to
work in data um there's many talks about
what is it that recruiters are looking
for there's a lot of talk about how to
think about the career with like mostly
based on people examples but I was
hoping to do something a little
different that maybe is a bit more
theoretical uh and that looks at the
current Trend especially around the use
of large language models and intelligent
agents whatever we uh we expect to see
coming out of that Big B old Revolution
now um and see if that is going to
change the way we do our work if it's
going to be the same can of change that
we've seen in the recent past
um
the the honest uh way to look at what I
wanted to make was I don't know a lot of
times people talk from a point of view
of experience from of your
confidence I don't know what's going to
happen for the data jobs however you
want to Define them in the next two
three four five years I've been doing
that job for almost 25 years now so I've
seen two three four five revolutions
depending on what you want to set the
bar and they've all followed the same
kind of logic that is hard to recognize
from the get-go but I think the
gentleman that you see the photo now on
your screen Ronald Co is someone who
offered a really good framework to think
about it and I would love to explore
with you uh and hopefully that's going
to be interactive um what does the way
he looks at organization can help us
think what is the role of a data and
what will be the impact of having what
looks like semi-intelligent
uh language models um what would that
mean in the uh what would that mean for
us in the medum term and would that just
would that change a lot of how we we
think about our own
job the uh it's very much an attempt for
me to force myself to speak out loud the
kind of ideas I've had and to see if
they're Mak sense to peers um so I'm
very much hoping to have a some sort of
feedback there's a QR code uh on your
screen so if you want to participate uh
you can scan the QR code to your phone
you're going to be on a dedicated
version of this presentation or
otherwise you can go on m.com and type
the uh eight digigit code so that's
0757 that should put you in like a
version of this note and whenever I've
got questions for you hopefully that's
you can participate I'll leave that
screen for an extra
second um
this tool is mostly meant for like
quizzes so I would recommend you use it
if you have like puup quiz or like if
you want to do something a bit fun with
friends uh it's also really helpful if
you want to have feedback uh it's tool
that was developed by a company called
Benta in Sweden where most meetings are
very um sort of like everybody
participates quite actively everybody
has to speak but extensively that tool
allows them to have the same kind of
contribution participation even if
you're in large group and I think it's a
really help tool to go
from tiny head into the screen talks at
you or for my version I'm just speaking
at my computer like I'm a little
deranged hopefully that tool can allow
us to have a bit more interactions um I
think Zoom is a really good tool for
that but having a bit more structure
around it it's going to be really really
helpful one of the the first questions I
would ask uh when we see that kind of
question is what would be the kind of
advice that you've heard uh what would
be the kind of things that you would
advice you would give what would be the
the kind of precautions that you would
make nowadays I'd love to get a bit more
of your impression of what you expected
from this talk and a lot more
understanding of what's
your what is your understanding of the
current uh how do you think about your
career how to think about the job market
how to think about the work
itself
I'm not seeing a ton of
response so I might just move on uh
hopefully um this code should be active
for a little bit longer if I understand
properly how this works uh so hopefully
if you see this uh as a recorded version
you can still scan the code and uh go
back to um to answer I'd be very
interested in see what your answers
are one thing that I just want to uh
clarify before go forward is what this
talk is not meant it's not a tactical
talk about how to win during interviews
uh there's very good tricks on how to do
that I'm more than happy to go through
that step by step especially if we um
tomorrow I'm spending a bit of time at
mentoring session so more than happy to
go through it I think not everybody
needs the same kind of feedback one key
thing for instance is how much you speak
and it's very difficult to tell people
you should speak less or you should
speak more because it really depends on
how much you speak already um it's also
like not think I'm very good at I've
never considered myself being
particularly great at interviews I get
stressed quite easily and that's not
very helpful it's also not to talk about
how to have some sort of hack to get
your carrier to be at a better pay
position typically have to be a manager
there's definitely elements that to help
to think about how that role is
different from this role so that can
help structured at thinking but uh it's
not just to talk about here's what Sena
means even though there's something I'm
going to cover and more importantly this
is not a talk where I have clear answers
I don't know what's going to happen I'm
scared if I'm being honest um I'm
guessing you hear that in my
voice um I wish I had clear answers I
wish I had the ability to say here's
what's going to happen in two three
years and see what you need to do if you
don't want to be left
behind but I'm not sure um a lot of
people are scared because of LM because
of
very abstract concepts of violent
accelerations or things like that I do
not believe those changes I don't think
this is realistic at in short term it
just sounds confusing to me at best
but I've seen a lot of technological
transformation industry um 2001 before
that with the computer the tech
bubble there was people that
misunderstood what was happening that
took Trends and just extended them
further than they were supposed to which
is a very common problem I think this is
what's happening with the um AI
accelerationist uh position is just they
take a trend they're just assuming it's
going to explode because it looks
exponential for now I remember seeing
that around 2007 2008 when the word dat
scientist to B it was a
big um it was a big relief for me
because I finally able to explain what I
was doing I had been doing that job for
like almost 10 years at Point with like
a clear word for it which was a bit
frustrating um there was a big change in
how much we were able to do around the
Big Data Trend around having cheap
mobile SW ads and so the job we have has
changed but it has always changed in two
direction it became valuable and it
became bigger more impactful more data
better tools it became better in that
way uh there's been some tremendous
effort around tooling more recently
since 20178 with DBT for the reporting
side and the whole we need to think
about uh data um analytics the the
analytics as an engineering profession
as I think which I think is really
helpful there's been tremendous progress
around mlops in the same period that
like there's dozens of Tools around that
all those have made the job smart better
more structured more helpful more
recently there's been some rub uh with
uh everybody working remotely in 2020
and people coming back it wasn't
necessarily a bad thing because I think
it should have helped a lot the data
jobs but things didn't go as smoothly as
I would hope then uh a lot of people
lost their job but more importantly most
companies were not able to understand we
could look at how the data team think
about information and use that to
improve our own internal process there
was a missed opportunity there that for
me felt
worrisome and more generally I'm seeing
tools that are coming out now that are
incredibly good at doing the work that I
would consider be a core part of what
we're doing but I'm not necessarily it's
not super obvious for me what is left
for humans to
do um a very common Ben for a lot of the
progress we've seen is you can automate
away the boring mechanical physical part
of your job you don't have to run
somewhere or take a horse you can use a
bicycle or a car you don't have to uh
compute by hand you don't have
calculators and that left people with
high level functions I'm not sure this
is going to be true and that's why this
one to talk about
is I want to explain what are the basis
for the reasoning because I think
they're relevant in next case they
illustrate what we're trying to do a bit
better but I don't know if this is going
to be as effective as your I don't know
I would love to get your take on where
do you think is left how does that model
explain what you're going
through I'm going to cover essentially
four topics one is uh where this talk is
from I've breached on that a bit really
but just a bit of my experience in
detail of like different Revolution I've
seen I'm going to talk about how the
data field has had an increasing amount
of keywords an increasing amount of
abstractions of concepts of patterns and
this is key of the evolutions now I
think a key thing to understand how llm
work is this concept of pattern
[Music]
um third I'm going to just go briefly
through the kind of economic modeling
that I think is relevant for what we try
to do and uh finally hopefully with a
shape of a conclusion but maybe less
conclusive than that a bit of what does
that mean for our carriers if I'm being
honest not just yours and makes
sense the last decades for data tools uh
C two and a half for me but maybe more
or less for you have had a very common
pattern I've talked about the bubble
talks about theion of dat scientist or
the idea of big data and the bigger
Promises of the more recent models I
remember um this is a photo from an
event uh that was before P data was a
big thing there was something called Big
Data this one was the the event in Paris
and there was a lot of very promising
presentation of people who were winning
kagle competition and show the kind of
framework they applied and they were
like we can just use that and basically
you don't have to do your work of
selecting features doing features all
that can be automated
and the question I wanted to ask at the
end of every one of those presentation
was does this mean we all out of a job
the first time it was a bit of a mockery
then it became a bit more serious
because it all got better there was a
point because I was a monthly meeting
and I pretty much asked that question
every time after a year and a half two
years that just became an internal joke
and people knew they had they're going
to have to ask that question they were
going to answer that
question every time the answer was well
yes I've kind of oversold the product
because of course everybody's going to
lose their job um but it allowed people
to think here's what's left here's what
my tool is now asking you to
do um and I think forcing people in that
reasoning really help think the tools
don't replace you they've raise you one
level but I don't know if this is what's
left the document that Illustrated a lot
of what we had when I talked about the
job typically there was an ambiguity a
lot of people a lot of tools helped with
the yellow box and the job became all
the other boxes and that's what does the
job mean that contradiction was I think
really insightful that graph with
different versions because there's
versions with different task in
different box makes uh makes a lot of
sense one thing that I think came out of
this discussion was the the organizer
for that event is floran way 2 that you
probably know as a CE of day IQ which
was one of the very first framework who
was able to see that AI was not just
Tagle tricks to take a given data set
and turn it into uh a good model there
was all these other boxes around and Z
IQ was trying to take over make those
boxes a little bit more managable a
little bit better rather than just uh
offer like a really great tricks and
tips and patterns for the orange
one one thing I would love to ask I
there's not a ton of orence
participation so I don't know if I
should expect much but if you see any
kind of anything missing in that
graph uh for me there's definitely one
uh which is
around are we training for the right
kind of model is are we aligned is that
model actually going to be helpful for
once we have this decision this
inference is that something we can use
to to make better sense because if I can
tell you what you're going to buy uh
that means I can have high click through
for ads but I'm not going to raise your
profile I need to figure out what you
wouldn't buy unless we showed it to you
so it's a slightly different question I
think those Twi that kind of important
the
question but you can ask that questions
once you fixed a lot of those boxes and
that has led overall in the the industry
to increased
specialization we am going to go into a
bit more detail afterward but we went
for like a single Loosely defined job of
data scientist to more than 10 distinct
rules that just do not have the same
candidates to a point now then like
people ask am I a data engineer or am I
a machine learning engineer or am I an m
and I if I can talk to you i' be
reasonably obvious what you should take
what is the thing that actually interest
you but these are not the same carers
that increase I think is really good
because it help people be more effective
focus on things I care about but I don't
know if that's going to
continue
uh there's a forest of tools I don't
want to put on screen because it's just
going to take over the entire space but
like of all the different vendors all
the different partners all the different
Frameworks and we went from two or three
good ideas to 15 good ideas to hundreds
of vendors and at this point it's
impossible to describe what is a good
data stack but you can still somehow
make sense of it because a lot of them
have share patents share ideas share
Concepts uh it's bricks that I put
together to to making sense and I think
that modularity is something that has
been incredibly
helpful uh and that has help people
navigate this diversity uh and that
helped
people
um understand data functions as clearer
because they're clearer because they
make more sense there's an increased
amount and this increation has been
incredibly positive for the scenaries
the number of people involved and the
impact we can have uh now everything is
improved by data materially every
interaction you can imagine and that is
I think really really positive but I
don't know if that's going to continue I
don't know if LMS are going to
change um
another slide where I mention your
participation I'd love if you uh you
want to do the Q&A should be open I
believe uh no question from the
audience but the if you want to ask
question here on um slack on Zoom I'm
more than happy to uh to answer
but I'd love to get I can talk about
mytic experience and how the question I
kept asking at the end of one specific
conference was helpful but I love to get
your take my thinking isn't clear and
that's something I want to make sure
and I think the point of this Workshop
would be for us to think how to apply
the Frameworks that I'm going to talk
about a bit
later uh so I see a question jar uh if
you go on mentimeter M and use the code
1768 0757 you should be able to uh
follow along uh the information is here
at the top of the
screen first thing I don't want to go to
too much detail but it's the um the idea
that data has increasingly had uh more
keywords there's roughly three families
of data rolles at the moment uh
historical one the one that I was B
sorry bra for is just the r of analyst
that was doing reporting here's what's
happening the work St decision
presumably came from uh someone in the
17th century who wanted to know how the
state was doing hence the name that is a
very old approach but it has specialized
not it hasn't changed that much compared
to the other two the second one is what
has been called the date scientists
later which is to make interferences
it's not just here's what's happening is
here what we can guess happens here's
what people you probably want to
recommend here's things that could have
happened otherwise it's counterfactuals
is that abstraction that has been big
focus of the job for a while and a lot
of what p is talking about is tools that
help do that second part a bit better
the reporting is key part of it but it's
you can materially different the part
that is quite new and I don't know how
much of p is dedicated to that part but
that's a part has been quite
revolutionary in the last year is the E
effort of generative uh
tools this was formerly creative people
this was until now it was people that
had nothing to do with data and this
kind kind of a takeover there that is
kind of original and new but all three
of those have the branches have evolved
with very different roles with very
different constraints key Ro of analyst
is typically to make dashboard to curve
to show people something that they're
not able to see otherwise either
production or for operation
analyst second role historically that is
very common in like I would think very
key is the role of an a testing
statistician someone who's able to
understand T Test and have what the
constraints around it this one is
actually kind of rare uh we'll see a bit
later why uh but this has been the two
historical kind of part of the role the
one role that has emerged in 20 15 years
ago that is now very well set is someone
who's building data by plan who takes
data from one place to another there's a
whole uh abstractions around the concept
of ETL the formalism around it that has
evolved and that made this job
reasonably well def find quite early
it's not someone who say anything or
does anything interesting someone who
shapes the agent the right way and
between this this role and the the other
two there's been a layer between that
has it f thanks to certain type of
tooling which is now they have the right
kind of data you need to change it shape
and that is present in the ETL Acron
it's the t uh part of the uh or the elt
part of the processing so you can
extract and loow data engineer and then
you can transform it with an analytics
engineer that is mostly because the idea
of having a separate object of the data
model but is I'm not trying to answer
questions but I'm making you answering
those question something that is more
intuitive because the data is struct
properly a key pattern in that reporting
family of data rols the inference Ro is
the RO that most of you are more
familiar with uh the lot statistical
work name dat scientist was relevant but
they has split into mchine learning
researcher which is people who try to be
a bit more creative and Innovative and
publish paper around it or M learning
engineer someone who DED to apply it but
that wasn't enough because you were able
to write code that was stable you still
had to host it you have to make sure
that the service you had was something
that other teams could rely on hence
they need to rely on devops and a
specialized version of devops machine
learning operations and so we now have
one job that has split into at least
four different jobs but it kind of makes
sense and that's just not it one of the
more common inference that now people
are making because there's I would say
an overflow of satis that because
they've G have a bit more free time is
to think of less obvious inferences
things like causal inference
models uh that is a non-trivial piece of
work and something that generally
requires some level ex we get for
instance for PhD in economics or
something similar and that
is an evolution that came from this
increase
stability uh of uh this decrease
availability because the tools are
getting better and you can automate and
you don't have to worry so much about
how well by model not they have solution
the job that is new and that is because
it's new doesn't come with all the
baggage of the other previous one it's
job of around generative AI the big OB
is deep learning researcher but that is
a job that is rare because the resource
that needs are now within billions of
dollars you don't have that many company
that are able to have that kind just the
framework and the resource around it but
it is a big it's probably the most
explosive job the one that is appearing
that is not well defined is around
security or ethics
researcher it's still very much a data
job it's
still asking people to understand the
dimensions the finaly of
a um of what is a data object but it
has it inherits from philosophy and hits
from safety in a way that is quite new
and I think the role that most of us
have more familiar with that makes the
most sense the one that we've seen the
most talk at conference like P data is
people talk about prompt engineering I
wasn't very convinced this was a real
job but one thing that is absolutely
real job is someone who does all the
glue on top of the prompt engineering
it's someone who implements a custom
version of a rag someone who uh
implements a custom version of chain of
thought that integrates that into uh
front end that is internal to the
company that is able to connect the
closest I can think is people that until
recently we're just messing around
around s these are not necessarily
always technical people but a lot of
people that have been hacking around the
pis fa have very keen around that that
kind of
effort question I would love to ask for
participants if uh this is something Mak
senses have I missed anything do you
feel like there's more than the 10 rules
I've described just now that have
appeared in the last 10 years around the
data spere
um the reason I want to just explore
that diversity is I want to
later argue that for each of those roles
you want to further break down into
individual task and you want to figure
out which one of those task is something
that an LM can take over entirely which
one of those tasks something that can be
automated by a pattern which one of
those tasks is something that is going
to lead to more tools that lead to more
specialization you have this process of
I was I had a
model uh and I um because hosting that
model and training that model was like
different job we have specialized
business analysts definitely I would
think of business as someone who's
either an operations analyst or product
analyst because I see a difference
between those two but that is I would
say the first job I mentioned AI
sustainability
researcher I haven't heard of
sustainability other than the context of
um how much energy data centers take I
even if thei data centers are a lot
larger I don't know if there's a
specialty there but yeah I think that
makes sense to uh there's a friend who's
trying to make that data centers only
run when the electricity they're running
on is uh renewable it feels like it's an
operational data scientist more than
anything else but there might be some
specialty there that I'm uh that I'm
missing but yeah those I think are
really good examples of RS that we want
to see what is the person doing on a
day-to-day basis what are the task and
are those task things that we can
automate either framework or uh a data
pattern the
um
the key concept when you try to look at
what is our job the key concept that you
keep again and again is the idea of data
patent it's a way to organize data that
makes lot sense you have the first
second third fourth and now I think
fifth and sixth normal form of how to
organize a table you have the idea of a
session the idea of a funnel the idea of
a subscription
flow there's a lot of those dat patterns
that essentially are very standardized
way of looking at things
there are also data patterns that
are they cannot be standardized even if
the idea itself is easy to share one
common thing is if you look at churn you
want to understand why people churn and
so you want to look at what's the last
action one churn this makes L sense but
it has to be tailored the reason I make
this distinction is between standard and
tailor I think standard is going to go
into tools and it's going to be easily
to reproduce and it's going to be
something that no one does because well
if you have like a list of data it's
easy to imagine a software that's G
given data with like a reasonable shape
of list of events he's able to infer
what is a funnel you you it wouldn't be
someone's job it would be the person who
looks at that is someone who's not a
data person because that's can be
reasonably well tomated while there are
task where even if the pattern itself
makes sense like Cal
analysis uh you still need someone to do
a lot
of a task that's only a data scientist
or in this case of statistician this
case of last SE like a product analyst
to tailor the tools properly and so for
me the reason is is that is is that a
job I'm going to lose yes
um there's ways if my job is to do code
review or part of my job is to code
review I expect LM to be able to do code
review in a way that is Meaningful
enough that it won't be meaningful part
of my job maybe I'm missing oh no if for
instance someone's job is to do ml
hosting because that's a very common
pattern too
I would expect most people to now be
familiar enough with Cloud providers to
be like this is a shared this is a
standard way of doing things and we're
not going to have meaningful
improvements if we don't host them
ourselves unless we're in a very
specific unusual use case like we have
to host on premise or something like
that the benefit of those patterns is
that not just they take over your job
but also they allow you to make the job
a lot more flexible I talked about
hundreds of vendors it makes sense
because you have those patterns because
you might not know exactly what amaz
Athena does you you have names but
you're not the it's a it's a sensical
question to ask what is Google's version
of Athena that is like if you ask that
to most experien SCI like oh yeah I know
what that means because they have a
concept of machine learning hosting
system and they have a concept of Athena
and they won't just say oh this is so
they say that one exists but like those
features and that features actually are
in a separate tool because the breakdown
of tool is a little bit
different and data patterns is not just
within there's like code patterns famous
uh but beyond just code patterns there
work patter the idea of Version Control
people think of it as connected to code
it doesn't have to be lawyers would have
to use Version Control for instance uh
if you write Dungeons and Dragons having
a Version Control that would make a t
sense there's actually versions of
Dungeons and Dragons but forking would
make sense in that context so a lot of
the patterns that we have around uh our
work are things that if we formalize and
make sense of them we can do what I
think is the most common advice and
that's when I ask what kind of advice
you've heard when you into it a lot of
the answers I would expect along the
lines
of think of your work as an increasingly
sophisticated work that is this peer
programming someone ask someone how to
do what is the pattern to do things is
because of
this very long list of U tasks that
evolutionary better uh typically if you
are a data engineer you want to think
about events that you can aggregate into
totals and then you can draw curves and
then can say here's what's happening and
then if like someone did something
yesterday you can see oh look here's
where the curve would be so you can
infer the impact and like what's the
relationship between you as promotion
and how much sales you get that is a
great gen in evolution and you have here
a list of OB Evolution observation Trend
hypothesis theory that is like typically
what you would expect to have around a
product analy or someone who runs a test
table database metrics goal three
strategy that is the kind of evolution
you expect from someone who is trying to
Define goals for an organization all
those lines have this the job that is
kind of attached to it you want to have
someone who's increasingly uh Talent
that writing code and you can have
scripts you can fit in Notebook you can
have a code base that defines a separate
Library you can have just a self-hosted
service if you want to use information
to convince people you have anecdotes
that can turn into a story that you can
influence people with that's gradient
those you don't want just to use a
couple of themers you want to have a
whole thing about it it's a very common
pattern you would see and I think that
is a very valuable
thing but that Evolution implies that
automations and machine are going to
take the first steps and know how to go
from the first to the second to the
third step but the fourth and fifth step
are still going to be left over because
this is harder you want some experience
and until now all the tools of the
patterns make more sense early on there
is a systematic way to turn a notebook
into a code base and turn a code base
into a library this is something you can
reasonably expect a large language model
to make property uh but posting that as
a service you have Frameworks until you
can do it we still expect to have some
sort of ments same thing if you want to
have some sort of uh influence uh you
can automate drafting a presentation but
making that conversation compelling
making conversation is going to address
someone's concern that it still feels
like something that human would
do and I'm not
sure that hierarchy is still true I
don't think we're necessarily going to
be pushed by the bottom into more
interesting more thoughtful more
experienced more senior tasks because LM
have proven reasonably effective at
doing certain thing so so far we've lost
jobs through specialization because
those patterns allowed us to go up so
far we've L job to automation uh
especially through external tools uh
because people realize oh I've used this
and this at Google so now I can just
sell it as a function of this at Amazon
and something that people want to buy
and so one of the red stance of job that
has been lost has been lost because they
were not super high valued jobs and they
were merging to someone else so making a
funnel not exciting but now it's
something that you can do with a tool
and something that like a product is
able to just click click and get with a
no system get a version and now they do
the last version of a follow which is
make decision on where is a step two be
fixed that means that in that case we
did lose a job it's a job nobody really
wanted because like it's not exting
making funnels is not just exciting
task but
that that
transformation assume things about the
DAT to work that are not super true the
actual day to work
is less at the top and more between the
cracks all the abstractions that I
talked about all this list are just have
leaky
Concepts uh one key thing is what people
actually do when they're finding like if
someone is spending time or something
it's probably they have a model but
they're trying to turn it into like a
system that they can build so the docker
is not really working because you have
dependency conflict they just don't have
the right permission because they don't
know what to store the secrets properly
or they have to replace secrets and like
it just doesn't work all the has like
not of memory and
crashes that is something that is still
something we have to do something that
will probably be the work that is left
for humans because a lot of those feel
like something that llms are not
necessar good at doing but it's not the
highest level task that it's not
architecture an llm is really good at
architecture uh and will get better I'm
not sure a lot of data scientists are
that good at building a good much
knowing
architecture another common problems uh
that we deal with is plastical issues
like you have values that are nulls
because there's some sort of issue you
have the data skewed because there's
some balanced uh you have a model shift
andil to detect you have outliers out of
bounds those problems I feel like even
if they feel unusual and weird because
your Solutions are more standardized
they can be taken over by automated
system so I would be surprised if they
were not solutions that make sense that
went better than two common tools open
source tools or probate
tools and uh
the the one aspect where I see the most
Humane parts of the
problem but I'm not I don't know if
large language B are going to take over
is the G Mis alignment problem is is it
what we're doing does this actually does
it make sense to what the the rest of we
try to do um we are building a model
because we think that better
recommendations or recommendations that
have more in their directions are going
to increased conversion rate have we
validated this assumption how do we
validate this
assumption a very common uh presentation
that does out reasonably well uh is
presentation by bman who's very active P
data Amsterdam and
Hoven um recently like two weeks ago he
did a talk atone we talked about uh
disappearing
gorilla sound bit like he hi he h a
gorilla in a data set and ask uh two
groups of people to answer questions
humans one of them was given us a
general task I there one I like specific
questions to answer those who
certification miss the gorilla
that's machine would not be able to gor
because they wouldn't be realized that
there's something weird
there but
um this we miss something because we
have more structure is I think
instrumental into thinking what is our
job
what are the parts that we can take over
and Vincent's example are quite common
because he made many presentation on
around this topic around artificial
stability or like other Concepts around
how around falce labeling and this
application of patterns
is hiding the
danger uh the Leaky abstractions behind
those and so I'm not necessarily
confident that having a machine that
applies pattern blindly is going to be a
better version of a more systematic or
cheaper version of a of a date
scientist but that's because there's not
just patterns of how to do things there
so very common patterns at mistake V
described some of them uh quite
artistically but there's stories that
didn't make sense that they actually had
a job in real Comon like the lampos
fallacy where people say oh um story is
someone looks lost the key Luke's behind
lampus like did you lose your key here
like no no but that's where the light is
I thought this was completely really
this story doesn't make sense until
actually work data and people do that
all the time they do this
um we want to optimize for metric is
like that's not a metric like that would
actually be impacted by your change like
yeah but that's the metric I have um
same thing for the dots on a plan for uh
selection bias fallacy those and more
generally more psychologic effects are
well
documented and llms are familiar with
those so even if more systematic pattern
free humans to have more
insightful more
uh irreverent take if you want to take
Vincent vman's approach to to dates they
are
not the this is not something that anlm
would not be able to
do one example that uh is related to
that is s m here of open AI have talked
about how LMS are going to be more
convincing than humans and and they're
really good at providing adaptation to
the certain issue so if you say I might
you might not be optimizing for the
right model a human might shrug and be
like yeah but that's the data we have a
machine would be able to say oh so we
need to collect data here's how we can
convince someone to have the budget for
that data they're not really good at it
now but I definitely expect llms to
evolve Beyond KNE patterns that
definitely learn you can see that the
way they do objectoriented programming
the way they able to uh if you ask them
any what how do you do fun is they be
able to be really good at it so they're
very familiar with the the patterns but
they're also familiar with how leaky
they
are so they can if you give a data
template answer open business question
so you say here's what my data frame
look like can you tell me where what was
which data has the both sales or can you
tell me you know what is what where we
should invest our marketing budget to
get more increase they would be able to
run the SQL code and like get that
inference but they also that's not just
give them the DAT temp plat is if you
give them
the description of the company with uh
reasonable data uh data shape they're
able to turn that into a usable data
model so they're going after the DAT
work same thing for
templating the uh they
have the Train on code that was
refactored on code that was revised on
code review on how to configure service
so if you say I have a service that I
want to do this and that how would you
the pro file to be able to host it on
this service they would be able to do
that reasonably well and give you really
good advice around it so they
have Beyond unusual liability to
understand framework but if you want to
go beyond that they are increasingly
able to uh to make sense if you have if
you're able to share the right context
with them they're able to report on
activity and understand outlying element
so it's not just standard analysis it's
here's something that you want to look
into they can make suggestions based on
those outliers around what the
assumption could be and so they can go
at the highest level of what I would
consider analy job to be they can draft
action ban and I can't show whether that
thing so this ability to suggest ideas
check that they're okay and if those
ideas are okay challenge yourself to
revert which is something that humans
are not that good at I think those
models are actually pretty good at doing
it the
last thing I want to war people against
that Revolution is a lot people say oh
building those mods would be cool that's
what I want to do I don't think a lot of
people are going to train them because
is so expensive a lot of people are the
very large system the thing that is
exciting is really good a lot what
people are to do is the plumbing around
it either building um adaptations
building retraining refining models all
the a lot of the work around refining is
doing the other work just as it was one
yellow square and all the things around
LMS are going to have the same Forest of
what is the right kind of metric what is
the kind of reporting what is the right
kind of uh issues around it that are
essentially the traditional data
work but someone who understands that
can be powered bym tools to build that
extension around and I don't know what
work is
left and that's what led me
to worry panic and go back to uh core
historical
ideas around what are data why do people
pay us to do what we're doing what is
the value into what we're
doing uh one core idea is the idea of
complimentarity uh it's a very common
thing in economics if you sell two
things together so waffles and ice cream
for instance on the screen if one of
them becomes cheaper than the other ones
become has more demand it doesn't have
to be more expensive but it has more
demand so you can sell more of it so if
you have like some sort of policy around
dairy farm and milk and you have S too
much milk and then you say oh going turn
all that make into ice cream ice cream
becomes cheaper that means you're going
to to sell more
waffers that seems a little bit uh
Stupid example but it has happened um
the book called prediction machine has
really good take on it around because we
have cheaper data
storage because we have cheaper computer
storage the role of analyzing that and
Gathering the data aning it has become a
lot more valuable it's economists who
look at companies and how they organized
and they have identified six things that
are really key to making decision like
Gathering data understanding it and
because of some of those become cheaper
so that's the uh Gathering the data and
analyzing it the things that are
compliment become cheaper too and that's
analyst and the one thing that is really
interesting in the model is because they
think of data as something that's is an
input into making a
decision the other inputs the other
compliment to that those become cheaper
therefore the key thing is what they
called uh judgment what you can think of
as alignment which is what do you think
is good because it's cheap to run a Navy
test now what became valuable
is if finding the right metric for Navy
test the second thing I say which I
think is really interesting and seem
counter intive unless you actually go
through model understand what they're
talking about is because making decision
is key is becoming uh more valuable the
ability to make decision is
key and uh therefore one thing they
mention is if you take a lot of actions
this is going to benefit you if you're
already a large player because you have
a lot of activity that you are private
to if you sell stuff you know who bought
it so you know what more they want large
company get this very significant data
gravity
phenomena and that intuition of Big Data
tools benefit big companies was never
spell out as cly as in that model and I
think that's really interesting thing to
do but this is still very classic
economics one aspect of it that is
interesting that is not very surprising
and that's what I've been talking about
with those patterns is an intuition
coming from front white an engineer
around atics who realized that the first
time you make an airplane is very
difficult and then gets greatly easier
and so for every what you call doubling
of production so the more the more
airplanes you make the easier faster
cheaper it is to make an airplane and
that is why we talk about craft why we
talk about patterns why we talk about
because the more machine learning
training you've had the more you know
what you're talking about and that is
also very class what so far what I've
talked about is very classic economics
but there's a more interesting take
there
c a century ago ask why do we have
companies because all the models talk
about individual agents and he was like
why is the organization why are they
Arch and I think the role of data is
emergence from what he's trying to say
here his key idea is economic talk about
Goods that you buy and sell but there's
another cost that people Overlook which
is a transaction cost every time you
make a decision you have to clarify what
decision is make sure you think right
decision and that has a cost and a lot
of the decision a lot of the structure
we see is coming from efforts to
minimize that cost the company is what
you call Nexus of transactions so you
have a lot of transactions happening but
those transactions have been pulled
together to be more effective and more
efficient and because they've been
pulled together they have a form of
rigidity he talks about butter in
buttermilk unless you actually done that
yourself it might not be a meaningful
example but he's there's harder places
things are still quite soft but there's
harder places in some places and those
harder places me you have reasonably
ened institution like a
hiaki uh your boss and people might
Overlook those but the reason they're
there is because they make things
cheaper having hierarchy or long-term
contracts really allow you to spend less
time finding a right kind of talent that
you would have if you have a contractor
or training workers because you know
they're going to be lowers the risk of
both you finding a job and a company
finding right kind of workers and it
allows people to coordinate on what
you're supposed to do because you don't
have to say for every contract here's
your task for the next days you say I'm
going to pay you per month and you're
going to do what you want within those
hours and we're going to decide what it
is as we iterate as we grow but here's a
general Vision having that allows to
have cheaper more world
connection and that's having that one of
the key thing that he informs and
something that you want to think of as a
DAT scientist and I think that's that
informs the the key thing is those tools
build versus build are are key because
uh
they uh they
allow you to think of is is what I'm
trying to do something that is
common that is not very difficult to
judge and negotiate something that is
like if you have it you know you have it
or something that has a high transaction
cost that is you have to evaluate you
have to personalize you have to think
about it if it's the first kind and it's
something you want to buy and if the to
you building is something that everybody
agrees works in the same way doesn't
need personalization then you shouldn't
build it internally you should buy it
from a vendor that's the trend that
comes naturally from the co uh model of
transaction cost
if something is uncertain that's
something you want to
build if something is trained on very
large data sets beyond your what your
own organization has ability then this
is something you want to build which is
why people are not entirely sure whether
or not Google open the eye have a clim
monopoly they're the only company who
can spend that much money on getting the
data and training it I'd be very
surprised if there were many large
company who do that kind of effort a
handful of company are going to some of
them are going to share them as open
source uh typically but that I think is
going to stay concentrated and uh if
what you have is actually train or
differentia on what you have it's not
just what people where people want to go
on holiday is where your clients want to
go on holiday then this is something you
want to build internally that first
distinction I think comes out naturally
from the model but I think where this
model is a lot more interesting for us
is it highlights how making decision is
expensive difficult and hard it's very
risky you might have some you want to
keep something ability in case your
position in the company is challenged
because you took bad decision you want
to have some psycholog safety to make
sure people are comfortable this make
know so those risk factors are really
essential and you want to coordinate
people that have very different approach
if you're in a website and you're trying
to get people through website as fast as
possible you want to remove all the
warnings about oh by the way this is
very small T-shirt so maybe you don't
want it but a customer service team they
definitely want you have those one
because I don't want to have people
coming back and like canceling orders
because they show it's too small that's
lack of alignment requires it's genuine
conflict that very difficult or more
systematically um you have multiple
things you could do you could do better
marketing you could do Outreach you
could do PR you could have better
products you could Rebrand you don't
know where to allocate your budget and
having coordin deciding what to do is
incredibly difficult
but a data role is a role that allows
you to optimize those decisions allows
you to focus on anomaly so if you have a
lot of things to do but generally things
go well you can grow your team because
system can tell you this is the person
that is selling less than usual so
that's a person who you want to see if
they're selling well the other ones have
like nor normal average number of sales
you don't want to worry about them it
allows you to have a typology of problem
you have many people complaining to you
as a manager you don't know what to tell
your team what to but if you're able to
take all those feedbacks and classify
them then you can say okay if these are
what the clients telling you here's the
response and here are the things where I
want to if you don't fall into that
expectation you want to talk about
myself so a lot of the data whether
reporting or inference allow you to
align all the concerns and let people
understand we're not not investing into
a
rebranding but the rebranding would be
expensive and not have a very impact
while if we do ads we know what the
impact would be and thanks to the work
of the data team we can measure that
risk and we can have people agree that
less risk is
better that's I think and that's a
personal opinion that is definitely
something I would want to discuss with
how you understand qu Theory and how you
understand your own role whether this is
the best way to look at the role we're
trying to
do one aspect of that that I haven't
talked about and this is by data impact
l so this is something we want to
highlight is I talked about organization
Co talks about firms as in for-profit
company because that's the example he
had in mind but there's been some
addendum around it around what is open
source how does open source work um the
key person there is El arrom who took
over and like expanded the work um he's
not she's not technically in Economist
but she was able to highlight
how organization can also emerge not if
there's a profit but it's as a shared
resource so she looked at PE Collective
like people especially around what to WR
and that think is a really good model
for how we think about open source the
first thing why people contribute is
signaling which is just lowering the
cost of you being hired so that is very
standard economic
model
um
the the the itas that no would like
organizations are the cheapest way for
groups of people without clear ties
without like obvious enforcement
mechanism to get people to incentivize
in the right way is I think really good
because she takes the same idea and
applies it in context that doesn't have
necessarily A strick
hierarchy um one word about because I'm
talking about llms and I'm talking now
about open source open source LM are not
technically open source because it's not
the same thing they they're refinable
but they're not reproducible entirely
that distinction I think is really key I
won't have time to get into detail
now um what is being shared is a site
prod of research and so it's just a f
that they make available without making
available the rest of the work or not as
much
um and because they think that uh
sharing has better
externalities less negative
externalities than the rest so if they
share with people who want to join their
company but they're not helping any one
of their competitors so it's not
necessarily the same mindset as open
source as a common something that we
want to all work together even if
there's a same intuition I think there a
meaningful difference and it's it's
about a single organization signaling
not maintaining that
common I'll break because I've got a
couple of questions uh let me just show
it you in the data
field in three5 what's your take is it
better to op for part-time freelance
gigs for diverse experience it's less
table pay
um I'm going to answer that's quite
controversially towards the
end but it depends on your own
experience if you have if you can get
good high level
gigs uh if you feel like what you're
doing is interesting and Cutting Edge
and you're working in tools that are new
I think it makes sense because it will
give you more diversity but mostly
because I'm very worried about where
organizations are going to be in five
through to five years I expect a lot of
replacement uh in 2001 like I remember
having every corner of every street a
travel agency those were gone because
internet was able to replace them more
effec it's not just travel doesn't a lot
of types of work that have High Street
Supermarket that were replaced by Amazon
I expect a similar kind of Revolution to
happen and I don't know what are the big
companies that I don't think that's as
stable as they claim to be even though
there are some big companies that have
digitalized properly that are now bigger
than they were
before uh so that's the so if you if you
have if you don't have that kind of
experience if you don't if all the
patterns that talk about something that
you're not familiar with you want to get
those and I don't think you people
invest in your expertise uh as a
freelancer as much and I think you're
going to get really good grade that is
you could because there's a lot of Open
Source resources so it really depends if
you're not senior I think working in a
stable institution will give you a lot
of space to learn those things and like
things that you wouldn't learn outside
of that context if you are senior I
think it makes sense to explore and like
get a better feel of what's Happening uh
I personally changed a lot of
oranization for the like when there was
some crisis not necessarily by just just
because the uh personal had to move
and that showed me things I didn't
expect to see
otherwise second part of the question
would you recommend for
stability
I'm I I'm worried that the stability is
something that is going to be disruptive
and I just one other key thing here that
I want to
[Music]
um uh that I want to to to to address is
uh me see how can I oh here
why is there diversity between an
organization and I think is a key thing
when you see oh you have like better
ways of doing things you can use Version
Control no I does it you can use
digitation like yesterday I was supposed
to sign a physical paper and the fact
that I wasn't in the same room as
someone else was a problem like I
haven't seen a sheet of paper in a
decade there's a very uneven
distribution of how those new patterns
Evol both like very basic things like
signing papers or very high level things
like not every company uses DBT not
every company uses the top of the Arts B
learning operations model even if they
would benefit from it and that's because
of innovator's
dilemma until that thing is proven to be
very effective trying is very risky and
people don't really know when it goes
from it's not risky anymore it's
obligatory but also because coordination
is incredibly hard as long as nobody's
losing their job they're not taking that
much risk and they're not trying the new
thing and if the system is working they
have no reason to be challenged
internally and that's where I think
travel engin you were not able to get on
the internet because of them would all
and they could not beat booking.com or
Skyscanner because they would didn't see
those as competitors until they
were
[Music]
um the last thing is a lot of people see
the way they're doing things as obvious
the way that's water doesn't make sense
of fish because it's they're surrounded
by it and it's very hard to get people
to say the way you do things is
counterproductive I've been trying to
write some f in someone like that's
someone is just keep sending me a
version of that document as an attached
file to an email and then I say you
should work with like Google Docs or
anything that is Version Control they
look at me like it was funny like did
that suggest that was like I'm not
trying to use Google Docs I'm trying to
use Version Control the fact that those
two things were separate that concept
the pattern wasn't something that was
obvious for them and that explains why
there's company that feel like they're
25 years ago there's why a company
that's like do the example I use usually
people using
teams even if everybody seems say hey
because that's kind of a set establish
and but people don't know that you could
do
better the person that if you want what
is happening with this llm and how
people work the key intuition is Eric
Bron who's the director of the economics
Lab at Stanford he's key inside his
night we're seeing a lot of automation
but those automation is not at the role
level it's petas and that's why I went
through like the different 10 different
roles I wanted to go to the Tas that
just didn't fit in like an hour format
um he sees some tasks being replaced and
not some not being replaced and that is
really good understanding what's going
to happen that's how he was able to say
that some jobs are just are not going to
be replaced not because the jobs are
particularly hard but because none of
the task of those jobs what people
actually spend time doing is just not
going to be replaced nurse is really
good is that all the task but like it's
a lot harder to explain than softer than
what it makes sense while someone who
does um expense review most likely might
might be replaced that focus on don't
look at the RO task really helps
understand what makes sense and which is
why I talked about patterns which is why
I talked about structure and habits that
is uh what it makes
sense the he's he doesn't think that
this idea of llm is a more sophisticated
tool makes sense because they can
replace high level task and so that's
one thing where I definitely would have
to agree with him on LMS can do high
level tasks that other people can cannot
do and finally the um the one thing
that's the one intuition from his res
that makes L sense is he separates
people that
use llms as a hybrid either the LM does
it or a human does it or Santos they're
both using the a human is using the to
at the same time and he sees that the
impact on the organization is very
different but one thing that he's quite
adamant and someone who's studing at
Innovation a lot is he sees innovator's
dilemma and full force uh it took an
incredibly long
time to uh get transformation from the
internet the organization are just using
process that was Z solo Paradox in
around 2000 people oh computers
everywhere so computers are going to
increase productivity and like sort of
was like I'm not seeing it in numbers
like and that was because people were
using computers as a proxy for paper
they were sending emails when they would
have send internal memos until they
realize oh no no we shouldn't have a
process that is essentially paper based
we should have a process using a very
completely different internal tooling
that is and that to people DEC case who
understand how makes sense
that's
that slowed people considerably uh and I
think people because they see O is a big
thing but they haven't changed my job in
the year therefore I'm fine I'm missing
the fact that the blue is going to come
harder later and in unexpected way a bit
like a text a wolf he's already above
the cliff doesn't know yet and he's
going to fall and hurt
himself um what is more likely to happen
and I think that's the answer to the
question that uh
I've seen
is the company if I could join something
I would join a company that isn't
created yet or isn't big yet but that
will leverage LMS in a way in a business
model that without it wouldn't make
sense an example of where I think like
would be fantastic is a company that
takes old customer feedback Aggregates
them into here's a feature that the
company needs to build here's something
you need to change
and turns that into code that behind a
future flag and ab test that to see his
customer said this would like this and
if you actually look at what's
happening this was something that made
uh this is something that actually
impacted that sa action or customers
said they like it we could do it but
then we lose money if we did
it how do you think about your own
career in that
context um I think going to change
things but I don't think it's going to
change the bulk of the advice I would
give in that context find something that
gets you excited find like um you life
is too precious to waste it on stuff
that you don't get accepted over so
please find a job Works where you want
to be motivated something that you want
to to make happen and your contribution
there is more Mak sense learn the craft
being good at something spending time in
like the people who give talks about F
to accept me know what they're talking
about that comes from spending time
doing it it's a myth behind 10,000 hours
and that will allow you to Signal people
I'm good at this and you can do that
with open source because that's a I
think really valuable visible tep to do
but just working in
companies if you are not super
experienced I would say learn go to
large because I can teach you
more and but they're not that Innovative
they are stuck in this process they do
things well but they don't do the latest
thing well because they've already doing
things well uh data engineering at meta
is not that exceptional because they had
really good one 10 years ago and it
hasn't as much as they
could uh and therefore because if you
want to be at the latest store with a
little bit of experience I would say try
open source try your own idea what can a
company give you a bit more freedom that
makes a lot more
sense how to navigates your existing
options
um if you want to if you manage to get
into a tool that you know everybody's
going to use share Tool uh set like that
everybody sense you will have large
impacts but it's a much smaller job
market and so I don't know how many a
testing company that would meets but
it's not 50 but there is job in uh
taking that tool and personalizing it so
being a consultant that helps company
who has an AB test to doesn't know what
to do I think there's a lot more
position there and it's a lot more
accessible in that sense but it's a lot
harder to personalize that service
automatically at least until the
yoga open source is fantas IC but it is
only project where the maintenance is
something that individuals can do
because they like because they're
motivated it can rapidly hit limits of
not having that much investment in them
n focus is trying to do tremendous work
there but it's still limited compared to
private investment and where
coordination can become rapidly
expensive because you don't have the
same organizational structure that you
would have uh looking at open source
projects versus companies with the lens
of coo and really shows you there is an
intrinsic issue there that limits what
can be done with open source that has
been proven wrong because the ambition
and the quality of a lot of the project
uh Pata is a fantastic example of that
uh but I you want to understand the
limits of maintainers have face every
day um he incites that nobody will deny
being a Jun now is incredibly hard
because remote and now I have just taken
over the opportunity to learn by PIR
programming by doing
shadowing is incredibly
hard uh Cal used to be a really good way
to train to signal that you really good
at eaching and and scating these are not
challenges as much as they used to be
and data that was ful able to scrape API
that were avilable or that is gone
because people not see the value they
have to join LM so now it's that is just
intrinsically hard I don't have good
answer for
that uh and finally transaction cost
will mean
that I just an exp ing on ideas might
get cheaper communication would be a lot
more effective if you can just not
listen to a meeting and like have a
summary that is
autogenerated but I don't know if that
means conization are going to get bigger
or smaller and that's I think the
misunderstanding from C model is if you
people think oh if communication cost is
less then companies are going to get
bigger both internal external
communication and cost so the
distinction between the butter and the
buttermilk is just going to move but
it's not going to mean you have bigger
cluster of butter or
smaller uh and
overall the adoption is going to be
incredibly uneven it took 20 years to
see computers in production numbers and
that's when Google was basically the
majority of the
economy and the key thing if you want to
understand what's happening is look at
you what you're doing break it down into
individual task and be like could that
be automated which is a very tedious
work and something that I've had to
do um I don't know if I've shared my
fears as Effy as I would like I don't
know if I've answered any of your
turns I was hoping to
um give framework around a question that
I've heard a lot much more recently than
in the last 20 years but uh it's not a
new question it's just more pressing now
uh and I've tried to answer the question
I got but if you have more questions
I'll be available uh on slack uh here
for a couple of minutes and otherwise
very easy to find online on LinkedIn or
elsewhere at Berto hats